if your vision is not routinely called
crazy then perhaps your vision isn't big
enough and disruptive enough are you
being busy being busy have you lost that
connection to the life you wanted to
live when you were a little kid you can
be a history maker or you can be liked
by everyone around you you can't be both
hello believe nation it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my sincere hope is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet so to help you
on your journey today we're going to
learn from bestselling author and
leadership speaker Robin Sharma and my
take on it top ten rules of success
volume two wheel number two is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like to buy also as
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down in the comments below a
book quotes around that so other people
can be inspired by it as well and if you
leave it within the first couple hours
of this video going live you have a
chance to win one of two daily prizes
every genius entrepreneur has an
eccentric vision so their possibility
reans they are the people who said you
know well here's the way the industry
has always been and here's the way the
status quo is but here's what we're
going to do what's coming to the top of
my mind right now
as I record this is uber so you've got
Travis Cal MEAC and literally through
that single app I mean they don't own
any taxis they don't own any cars they
don't really have any inventory but
through that single app uber disrupted
the entire industry of that level of
Transportation and so you know these
people these genius entrepreneurs come
up with a ridiculously disruptive idea
that is absolutely eccentric in its
vision and that's why people call them
crazy and I'll simply say to you if your
vision is not routinely called crazy
then perhaps your vision isn't big
enough and disruptive enough and we
changed the world when we change the
game and Bono is sharing the story that
I believe he heard and it was the person
walks inside Kanye West's living room
surveys the living room and cannot
believe what's on one wall of Kanye
West's living room and it's this giant
poster of Kanye West and so the person
who's in the living room goes Kanye it's
a beautiful living room but why do you
have this massive poster of yourself in
your own living room and Kanye replies
well if I don't believe in myself no
one's going to believe in me and my take
on that insight is simply this no one's
going to believe in your lofty vision no
one is going to embrace in a roll in
your mighty mission
if you don't viscerally believe in it I
mean no one's going to believe in you
unless you believe in you're in Kanye
you know in many ways is a disruptor in
his field and
kanya in many ways is playing at mastery
in terms of his craft but that's coming
from this incredible self belief and yes
I understand some people will say he's
arrogant and I in no way am encouraging
anyone to be arrogant or vain but the
larger point for you and I as people on
the rise to mastery and creating lives
that are legendary it's a really dial in
on that insight which is you know what
we really do have to have the confidence
to believe in ourselves because a lot of
time as a leader a lot of time as a
business builder a lot of time as a
craft person we will be in the
wilderness we will have an idea for a
business or a product where the rest of
the world says that's impossible
and we have to be coming from a place
from within where our I can is larger
than our I can you absolutely must do
the interior work required where you
have these fiery and levels of
confidence where when the world is
saying you know what I dismiss your
vision or that is impossible you have to
be that lone voice who goes no you know
what it is possible and just watch me do
it may have read my book the monk who
sold his Ferrari sometimes I speak about
Ferraris because I don't have a Ferrari
but I love the way that Ferrari rolls
and here's what I mean by that
a Ferraris in many ways mobile art on
four tires a Ferrari in so many ways the
distillation of Enzo Ferraris philosophy
on mastery a Ferrari in so many ways is
a reminder to you and me about what
world-class stands for and what I want
to really dial into today is this did
you know that every year Ferrari only
produces 7,000 Ferraris and the point of
wisdom or the powerful idea I want you
to really think about and deconstruct in
your journal tonight after this mastery
session is why go really wide when you
can be singularly deep I'm going to
repeat that again but a great company
and a great performer goes really really
deep on water
two things and that's how you rise to
iconic we live in a world I call it the
cult of superficiality addicted to
distraction afflicted by interruption so
we take the trinity of our performance
assets our mental focus our physical
energy and our willpower those are the
three primary assets of a world-class
producer and we diffuse them we disperse
them around thousands of projects lots
of little things and yet I think of the
7,000 Ferrari philosophy you know they
are world-class and in terms of
producing iconic automobiles vehicles
but they don't want to be they don't
appeal to everyone they don't produce
hundreds of thousands of vehicles they
want to do a few products they want to
bring out a few things but do them
really really royal and that's really
the craftsmen's mindset that's how
craftsmen think or craft to women it's
do a few things but do them really
really well you are an artist my
invitation to you is to produce poetry
in terms of your work that the world
reveals as mastery you know and that is
really all about bringing rigor to your
game it's not about doing a lot of
things it's about doing one thing well
because the secret of genius is not
complexity the secret of genius is
simplicity you look at any genius
entrepreneur you look at any genius
producer you look at any genius athlete
they're not doing five sports they're
doing one sport incredibly well and then
putting in the training time to be mono
maniacally focused so that they become
otherworldly brilliant at their one
thing and I guess what I'm suggesting to
you ultimately is this think about the
7000 Ferraris philosophy and if you are
a business builder let's say your
startup entrepreneur let's say you're a
fortune 500 manager let's say you're
professional athlete because a lot of
professional athletes are watching these
mastery sessions let's say you're a
mother or father or yoga teacher or a
chef
what are the few things that you could
actually do in your work so that you
take all of your mental focus your
physical energy and the willpower that
you wake up with every single morning
and you really mano maniacally focus
those Trinity of performance assets on
the few things the few projects that
when consistently iterated and improved
every day over time will allow you to
reach a place where the world calls you
world-class and if you can not only get
this idea on the 7000 Ferraris
philosophy but apply it so it becomes a
way of being
you really will own your game when I was
growing up my dad took out this poem and
he translated it from Sanskrit into
English and it was a poem from the
Bengali poet Rabindranath Tagore and
allowed me to share it with you it
simply said spring has passed summer has
gone and winter is here and the song I
meant to sing remains unsung for I've
spent my days stringing and I'm
stringing my instrument and my brother
and I used to look at it every morning
before we go off to school but I never
really understood it and so when I got a
little older I said dad you know that
poem you had on our refrigerator door
what was it all about
and my dad looked at me said he said
Robin that was a poem written by a man
whose heart was filled with regret over
a life half lived he said Robin that was
a poem written by a man who postponed
his life he always wanted to do
something special he always wanted to do
important work he always wanted to be
loving in the world he always wanted to
be creative he always wanted to see the
world but it got busy being busy are you
being busy being busy have you lost that
connection to the life you wanted to
live when you were a little kid are you
so busy stringing your instrument that
the song that your life was meant to
sing has died or is dormant within you
and my challenge to you is simply
this to do whatever it takes before you
sleep tonight to reconnect with the best
within you that you may have lost
because one of the things I've noticed
is this there are too many amongst us
walking the planet today who are sort of
in a waking sleep
they have lost a sense of who they truly
are and your life will never work if
there's a huge space between who you
truly are
and the person you know you're meant to
be your life will never be flooded with
energy creativity productivity and
happiness if there is a large space
between your life right now and your
unlived life and my request and
encouragement and challenge to you is
truly that you make things happen so
that the person you are starting
tomorrow is more of who you know you
truly are it makes me think of George
Bernard Shaw he was asked on his
deathbed what would you do if you could
live your life over again
and he replied after a long pause I wish
I could become the person I know I was
meant to be and I suggest to you it's
never too late for you to become the
person you've always wanted to be
but don't postpone it for next year
don't postpone it for next month start
being that person that human being that
creative force that business builder
that mother or father that athlete that
humanitarian that force of good that you
have always wanted to be beginning right
now you can be a history maker or you
can be liked by everyone around you you
can't be both I mean the very nature of
living your personal greatness and doing
something otherworldly in our world of
ours means you're going to have to think
differently from the majority you're
going to have to install the habits and
routines that most people don't do
you're going to have to live talk
breathe walk work produce create in a
way that most people who are
card-carrying members of the cult of
mediocrity just don't buy into when you
look at most people out on the world
today
and this is not judging this is just
reporting but they're addicted to
entertainment they love gossiping
they're negative they're toxic anyone
who wants to do anything great they want
to bring them down they dismiss the game
changers and they're just coasting
through life and so the very nature of
you stepping up your game living your
greatest potential owning your craft
dominating your field and living a life
that's legendary means you're going to
have to leave the 5% and make a decision
to live as very few people do and what
does that mean it means you're going to
be laughed at it means you're going to
be ridiculed it means you're going to be
misunderstood because leadership is a
lonely sport and it means you just might
be hated and so there is great value
when people start to hate you because if
you look at jay-z I mean I was reading
his biography and he said you know I
really knew that I was having influence
in the popular culture when people
started hating me if you look a lot of
the great authors when their books go to
number one globally a lot of the
amateurs actually start to say oh that's
garbage I could put them down I watched
a documentary last night on Steve I only
the famous EDM electric dance music DJ
who's getting so much traction in the
world right now and he was talking about
some of the comment that he sees in the
social media and it was things like
garbage and you know boring and
amateurish music and whatever even
though he's so skilled I mean you just
watch the documentary called I'll sleep
when I'm dead and you just see the skill
and you can just look at any great
athlete and you could look at any great
scientist you can look at any great chef
you could look at any great artist you
can look at any great author you can
look at any great statesman you can look
at any world-class stateswoman anyone
who has done something and an
exceptional level breeds cynics and
dismisses so the point is simply that's
the very nature of doing something that
very few people are willing to do
means that the majority will laugh at
you why because deep inside they know
they have the opportunity to do
something great too
and your example makes them feel guilty
and all I'm suggesting to you with great
love and respect to simply this you do
have a choice you can listen to your
haters you can be one of the haters you
can join the victim heard you can
dismiss people who are doing great
things or you can reach into yourself
and ask yourself this fundamental
question what I want to stand for for
the rest of my life do I really want to
rise to mastery do I want to get to the
last hour of my last day and know that I
took every ounce of a human potential I
was blessed with and through easy times
in difficult times I brought it on and
ever as a result of my values my
mindsets my heart set my habits my
routines my disciplines I was I owned my
game and I modeled possibility and I
served lots of people and I built a
great lifestyle and now it's the last
hour of my last day and I'm surrounded
by my loved ones and even though people
threw stones at me I took those stones
and rather than being knocked down I
constructed a monument of mastery that
stands as my legacy and if you live like
that you'll be one of the great ones
which is my greatest wish for you we're
in a restaurant the server generally
gives you what you expect or less than
what you expect you go into a clothing
store it's what you expect or less than
what you expect you do business with any
organization it's generally delivering
on what you expect but more often even
less so you have a gorgeous opportunity
to lead the field in everything that you
do by doing one thing practicing every
single day because it's a muscle the
ritual of over
delivering don't just give your
customers what they expect give them
10x more than what they expect don't
just give your organization what your
manager what your boss what the
organization is expecting from you show
something that is so rare in today's
economy initiative initiative so you're
asked to do a project give them five
more things than they expect you're
asked to give a presentation on
something go the extra mile
consistently dial in the daily habit of
over delivering on people's expectations
guess what you become a merchant of Wow
you become indispensable to your
organization I wrote a book a little
while ago called the greatness guide and
one of the chapters talked about the
importance of being indispensable and I
learnt that when I was a young lawyer
and I remember talking to my mentor and
I asked my mentor you know the top
litigator at this firm how come he is
the icon of the legal profession in this
region and my mentor look at me said
Robin because that person is
indispensable to this firm well how do
you do that by practicing the ritual of
over delivering every single day for the
rest of your life be yourself everyone
else is taken
well that really speaks to the power of
being an original it speaks to this
concept of authenticity being yourself I
mean we live in a world where there's
never been so much of a seduction to be
like everyone else there's never been so
much influence and hypnosis through the
social media and through society to talk
in a work certain way to walk in a
certain way to buy certain things to
measure your success by the same
philosophy and what I'm encouraging you
to do based on this Oscar Wilde quote is
to be yourself I mean talk your talk
walk your walk take the time to reflect
on your dream be true to your own values
because life's greatest heartbreak is
self betrayal make your icann more
important than even your IQ now you're
saying Robin what do you
think about right here well a lot of
people get stuck in victimhood versus
leadership by the seduction of saying
well I'm not smart enough I'm not
intelligent enough well you are
intelligent enough what's even more
important is your mindset of possibility
you see if you look at the best athletes
in the world the best musicians in the
world the best entrepreneurs in the
world the best managers in the world the
best CEOs in the world that coders in
the world the best pizza makers in the
world the best moms and pops etc etc
those who get elite level results are
not the most intelligent or naturally
gifted people in their field but these
are the people that have that mindset of
possibility and it's all about I can and
that might sound like a bit a bit of a
platitude you know having an attitude if
I can a mindset of possibility a
mentality of legendary but when you
really deconstruct it it's really true
the way you begin each day sets up the
way you live each day I mean the Spartan
warriors set it so well sweat more in
training bleed lessen war and if you
want to be literally undefeatable in
business literally unstoppable in life
you really want to dial in your morning
routine and so you want to do things
like starting the day sweating because
that releases BDNF brain-derived
neurotrophic factor that repairs brain
cells from stress you want to sweat
because that's going to increase your
metabolic rate which is going to give
you energy and we live in a world where
energy is even more valuable than it
intelligence you want to in your morning
routine take the time to write in a
journal so you actually can detect your
values reconnect with your goals each
day get to know yourself even more
because awareness is the beginning of
transformation and you want to get your
morning routine right so you take some
time at the front end of your day to
learn because as you learn more you know
you're going to achieve more
and as you understand better you can
achieve larger for the past number of
years I've been reading obituaries and
you might say Robin that's negative and
I don't think it's negative I think it's
really positive because I think few
things are as powerful to wake you up to
remind you about what's most important
to fuel your energy to get you into the
game so you let go of your fears and you
do what you need to do to get big things
done then connecting to your own
mortality when you realize that every
single day could be your last
or when you appreciate that no matter
how long you live life is a short ride
you just sort of let go of the fears and
you let go the limits and you live
full-on and you seize opportunities and
you have real conversations with real
people and you sort of wear your heart
on your sleeve and you bring on the
fullness of your authenticity and you do
whatever it takes to get your loftiest
dreams to get done and so I read these
obituaries and it reminds me about what
life is all about and relatively
recently I've started walking in
cemeteries I was in Mauritius a little
while ago it's I don't know if you've
been delicious but it's this paradise on
earth it's this tiny island about four
hours off the coast of Cape Town and
I've been delicious a number of times I
was there to give a big leadership event
you know I talked about leading without
a title so it was filled with iconic
CEOs and people running big industries
and big companies and entrepreneurs and
startup people and it was really
wonderful but I also took about a week
and a half just to refuel and to work on
my new book and to reconnect with my
values and to set myself up for the
coming months and one of the things I
did was I went for a long walk I love
walking I find interesting like I find a
lot of the most creative people and most
productive people in the planet
they all have one thing in common they
have the routine of walking on a regular
basis and so I love walking I've walked
in nature for many many years and so
here I am in Mauritius and I just
started walking and I was actually
listening to
an interview of Charlie Rose and Steve
Martin and it was done in New York in
front of an audience of a few thousand
people and it's about an hour and a half
long and Steve Martin was talking about
his career and Charlie Rose's one of the
great interviewers of our time so he was
asking about how he became so good at
what he did and his life and his love of
art and stand-up comedy and acting I
mean he Steve Martin became an actor
after a stand-up comedian etc and so I'm
walking and the Sun is setting and I'm
walking along the Indian Ocean and I'm
looking at the flowers and I get to this
little village and it's this really um
you know this little village with a lot
of character and as I'm walking along
the edge of the village still close to
the seaside I spot a cemetery and I
learned to follow my instinct more than
ever before because instinct is more
powerful than reason and life will lead
you to an interesting place if you stay
with the flow and so I walked towards
the cemetery and I walked into the
cemetery and I started walking through
the cemetery very respectfully and
carefully but it was interesting to me
because a lot of the tombstones were
just made of wood and somewhat sadly
some of the wooden crosses were actually
really really small and you could tell
that the grave sites were of kids and as
I walked through the cemetery I saw
these crosses and I saw some tombstones
some looked very old a few graves look
fresh and it reminded me really about
the shortness of life
I mean Marcus Aurelius has written one
of my favorite books the meditations of
Marcus are released and actually he
didn't write it Marcus Aurelius was a
Roman Emperor and during a long military
campaign in his journey
he wrote his thoughts and his
philosophies and someone found those
Diaries those journals and made them
into this book called the meditations of
Marcus Aurelius and he does talk about
the shortness of life and so does you
know epi' Titus and a lot of the great
stoic philosophers and being in this
cemetery and walking through it with
great delicacy it reminded me how short
life is and it reminded me we all have
hopes and dreams and we never know when
those dreams are going to get dashed and
you know we never know what our last day
will unfold some people wake up tomorrow
morning they'll get in their car now
they'll take a shower they'll have their
coffee they'll say goodbye to there are
lots of ones and that will be the last
day that their loved ones will ever see
them you know some people on the planet
the day after tomorrow will go into
their doctor's office to get the results
of a routine checkup and the doctor will
say sit down I've got some sad news for
you and will be diagnosed with maybe
some kind of a terminal illness I mean
accidents illness tragedy catastrophe is
also a reality of humanity and so what
I'm suggesting to you is do whatever it
takes to be in the moment and to stay
positive and to stay on your game and to
optimize your craft and to spend time
with your loved ones and to take care of
your fitness and to learn something new
every day and to enjoy the beauty of
sunsets and star-filled nights and at
the same time as much as possible please
do not lose perspective stay connected
to your mortality
you know Steve Jobs in that famous
Stanford speech said it really well you
know you are naked you have nothing to
lose and he learned that when he
connected to his cancer and so maybe you
will install a ritual once a month on
the way home from work you will pull
over to a cemetery and you'll spend five
minutes even in meditation looking
the tombstones looking at the crosses
studying the graves or whatever your
tradition is in whatever nation you're
from because not every tradition I know
has the grave site sometimes it's the
the funeral pyre which really reminds me
that life is really short and you never
know when your last day is going to be
and so just build some kind of a routine
to remind you on the shortness of life
so that you tell the people you love how
you feel about them so you write the
letters that need to be written and I
know people don't write letters but
writing a letter to someone you need to
express forgiveness to or gratitude to
is really powerful pursue the projects
that will allow you to be the legend of
your industry chase the passions that
fuel your joy and live every day as if
it was your last because we never know
when our last day will show up
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Jamal and asked
me to if there's someone you like better
profile in their future top 10 please
check out the link down in the
description below and you can cast your
vote on who we should do next I also
want to give a quick shout out to Jude
Jude thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word and taking
that awesome picture and sharing it with
me
I really really appreciate this part and
I hope you enjoyed the read thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
run your own race and that's really the
first lesson I learned from one of my
mentors run your own race stay in your
own lane you know you have no
competition if you are in your own
division and what I mean by that is
simply this it's so easy to get swept
off your game swept off your vision
swept off your values swept off your
focus when you're measuring your success
in your performance by your so-called
peers in your industry or your
competition within your craft and that
first lesson was so profound we simply
said run your own race you know come up
with your ambition come up with your
vision and have the singular focus and
the character discipline to say I'm just
going to put these blinders on and stay
true to myself true to my values true my
vision so I've been living my life
recently under one compelling standard
and simply this be only with people do
only the work and be only in the spaces
and places that fuel my joy I think life
is too short to be depleted and so I
spent a lot of my life helping people
rise to iconic as producers and
performers and creatives and
entrepreneurs and leaders and so what I
wanted to do in this master session is
really share with you some of the things
I do in my own life to fuel my joy fuel
my energy fuel my creativity and what
I'm really speaking up here is adventure
so if you talk to any good
neurobiologist they will tell you that
the brain craves novelty the way we are
hard-wired is to pursue joy to pursue
novelty to pursue newness and that's why
so often we start something but we
really don't finish it we're always
looking for that one new thing that will
fuel our joy fuel or ideation fuel our
creativity it's almost like we've got
this inner child within us constantly
longing to see the light of day and you
know adults are nothing more than
- rated children you never want to lose
that connection with that festive fiery
sparkling creative playful inner child I
mean you know the more you can connect
with that inner child the more you're
going to find your productivity growing
exponentially your creativity firing up
and basically you're just going out into
your industry and out into the world and
radiating positivity so what are some of
the things that I do to fuel my joy and
to keep that sense of adventure alive so
I don't lose the sparkle in my eye
traveling I just love being on airplanes
fundamentally I am a nomad so I love
being in Rome and eating the pasta and
experiencing the fresh mozzarella di
bufala or the burrata watching the way
the light falls over the architecture I
just loved Rome so much I love getting
up in the morning while the Romans are
asleep and running up to Monte and then
past the Colosseum and then past trevi
fountain I mean that is one of the
greatest runs I think on the planet at
least for me I love going to Mauritius
why do I love Mauritius it's this island
paradise where no one can find me and I
can immerse myself in creativity and I
can refuel you talk about adventure
going to Mauritius and swimming with the
dolphins is one of the things you need
to do on your before I die list before
you die I just love places like
Stockholm I love Latin America I love
the Middle East
I adore Europe I love London I love
Switzerland because I love to ski I love
going to India I love going to Southeast
Asia I love traveling the planet because
here's the thing I don't think there is
a better education known to humankind
than traveling Michelangelo is really a
great story on willpower and
self-control he was beaten severely when
he was a young kid by his father his
father wanted him to be pursue more
noble profession more lucrative
and Michelangelo wanted to be a sculptor
and his father beetle and his father
trying to get him off course and
Michelangelo said no I want to be a
sculptor finally through his grit and
perseverance and unrelenting this
Michael Angela's father said you don't
okay fine you're 14 years old I'm going
to allow you to go to apprentice with a
Florentine masters and he will help you
become a Salter and Michelangelo moves
the floor instead he started to study
they started to practice my god this is
a story of self discipline and world
class worked out through his mastery
into his practice and through his
suffering and through his persistence
and through his focus all of these great
loss traits that are no longer
celebrated in this world were all too
often people are card carrying members
of the cult of mediocrity through this
practice through this is devotion he
became well known he became known far
and wide he created that but this is the
beautiful sculptor David can go to
Museum of academia in Florence you will
see David you will see some of his other
masterpieces and part of that whole
region started to honor the way that
Michelangelo was appearing in performing
his assault because of his mastery a lot
of the other artists like Raphael the
Renaissance painters became the king
jealous and something devised a very
elaborate and interesting plan to
discredit and to ridicule Inklings and
Michelangelo spears went to the Pope who
was julius ii and they said to the Pope
wider to get Michelangelo to paint the
Sistine Chapel and the Pope said that
was good
and so the Pope went over to
Michelangelo and said I want you to
restore the greatness of Rome and the
grave is of Rome is now on your
shoulders because I want you to paint
the Sistine Chapel and I want you to
make it a masterpiece that holds the
world in awe when they see it and
Michelangelo replied to the Pope resent
you know I'm not a painter
and I've never painted I'm a sculptor
but Julius the second one is very
persistent and eventually Michael
Angeles I find I'm going to agree in
over four years
four hard years for years that took
incredible self-control incredible grit
we're going to talk about grid this
webinar incredible focus incredible
discipline Michelangelo created the
Sistine Chapel now let's put this into
perspective I'm upping Michelangelo I've
never painted fresco before Michelangelo
had to paint something on this ceiling
of the Sistine Chapel the people
standing many feet below because look at
that and see great detail Michelangelo
dealt with the fact that the painting on
the Sistine Chapel was moldy there were
painted shoes he had to deal with the
fact that the Pope was very ill and he
thought I might not get paid he actually
developed this incredible elaborate
system of scaffolding which allowed him
to paint to paint backwards for four
years on the Sistine Chapel in he
damaged his back in the process but he
did it for the arch he did it for the
discipline he did it for what it made of
him she did it for his commitment
because the great artists and the great
performers are much less about eagle and
applause and money and they do their
work for what it makes us them as human
beings and after four years
Michelangelo's eyesight was so damaged
from looking at the images on the
Sistine Chapel that he suffered
permanent eye damage but like I said
once he was finished the world was
awestruck at what he created and now
twenty million people a year go to the
Vatican and they do experience this
breathtaking work of art artistry and
human ingenuity constructed by an
ordinary man who exercised world-class
willpower named Michelangelo and so
ladies and gentlemen I guess what I'm
suggesting to you is one fundamental
points the myth of the talented genius
the mythic gifted genius is nothing more
than a lie society as
I don't know if I express that clearly
but what I'm trying to suggest to you is
the world says the Michelangelo and the
backhoes and the jay-z's and the
Oh
the great entrepreneurs the Carlos
Slim's the warren buffett's
the Jack Dorsey's you know the founder
of Twitter the Jeff Bezos is the founder
of Amazon the Mozart Matassa was in the
Box society teaches us and trains us
that these people are somehow born with
special talents and what I'm here to
remind you a deep respect for all twenty
five thousand four twenty four thousand
nine hundred twenty two of you on this
webinar from around the world is that is
a lie that society has sold us to keep
us small and if you look at the science
and science coming out right now he's
indisputable we're going to get at that
size but what science says is genius is
much less about I about your genetics
and much more about your self control
and your discipline genius is much less
of a natural talent and much more about
practice persistence focus great dealing
with sufferings dealing with failure
delia laughter well the world rest of
the world thinks you should stop genius
is much more about continuing practice
developing your craft